[Music]
in booming business news Oh submitted by
pineapple pizza can't be just pineapple
though savory sweet exactly some meat on
there I don't like juicy pizza make it
wet it could make you like tomatoes on
your pizza every single pizza in Italy
is juice no it's like those are because
then that's usually sun-dried tomatoes
no but I'm talking about like if you
have a margarita like papi that the
sauce is very popular so cultures
well actually the margarita pizza has
sliced dice we call this your roasted by
Phil I fight Tomatoes I know but you
said juicy okay juice juice or wet Jesus
is it called juicy fruit I could only do
one slice though that's my Mac it's like
my dessert Oh cuz it's the sweetness
mm-hmm well I do one home a 28 year olds
a 28 year olds company makes millions
buying from Walmart and selling on
Amazon he must be of the Asian nature
yeah this this has been has to be all
the time I used to do that on eBay you
can't cheat this is here for you yes
bill I take that back but it might be
Asian or Jewish Buddhist wrong Kumar
stereotypes his name is Ryan Grant
oh and this is what he look like whoa
he's like he has an asian wife though he
is East Asian is there a yarmulke on his
head he's Caucasian one of those I don't
know if he's Jewish
what's his wife look like hey Toshi go
ahead no he's from Minneapolis Minnesota
real agents he has mom from young
friends you have mom that's hot I'm the
way
the job used to be an accountant but he
quit his job after he started making a
really nice profit
that's a asian biography right no no
that's that's what happens when white
people learn accounting they turn into
shrewd businessmen without having a
dress hmm she's a business man she's
she's a she's a shrewd businessman that
white-collar criminal all right yeah so
he started off by reselling university
textbooks and he would have these
buyback events on his campus in Winona
State University and so he would have
these events twice a year and he would
list the books on Amazon and then ship
them out and he would turn a profit of
up to ten thousand a year just by doing
only the books as a student that's
amazing he started to think like well if
I can do this with books I can turn a
profit on other things too so then he
would start hitting up the discount
section or like the reduced price
section of Walmart and Target and then
once he was able to check on Amazon to
see how much profit he could get for it
then that's when he old by the certain
things that are on sale and then he
would turn a crazy profit on Amazon good
job smart but you know he's kind of dumb
cuz not everybody knows but no but on
Amazon you don't know but I think
everyone does no they're just lazy yeah
he's like I think anyone can do this
anyone can turn a profit like this is a
lot of work it's just that you have to
put in the words you know our buddy huh
he said he used to go to those on sale
section at Ralph's and buy it to stock
in his liquor store because there's
cheaper than a distributor sometimes
he's like sometimes you even get a
Gatorade forlán by 10 20 30 cents like
you can't beat that weeping oh my god
imagine if your Extreme Couponing and
then selling that [ __ ] right now
Wow blam mind of a poor man great
chicken knocking out the haters dude get
the [ __ ] out of here man all right so
how he be millions of this how much
shopping did you have to like how do you
even create having an inventory mean it
might be gross sales so how much is the
net
he quit his job back in 2013
so since 2013 he's been doing this when
he first quit his job he was making
about a thousand a month in profit and
then he would put in more time and then
three months later he went up to 9,000
in profit on over $25,000 in sales and
then finally he was able to expand he
went in 2014 he rented out a seven
hundred and twenty five foot warehouse
and then he oh he would just pack his
car with the long-wave just like in his
home he like it was tearing over his
house so he had to get a warehouse oh my
god this has to be illegal like some of
these products are not meant for resale
right yeah if it's I think it's dated on
there - yeah like soon will you sign
them early or just like this like this
will say not to be sold individually but
this comes in a box it does so if he
buys individual things or if he buys the
bottom they sell in the box I think it's
fine it's okay yeah yeah you can just
resell what whatever as long as you're
paying taxes I guess and he also needs a
resellers permit if he has one or maybe
he's selling everything to use no he's
buying a break well you don't need a
reseller permit if you're buying get
retail oh yeah maybe that's who's going
around it cuz wait wait wait wait no no
you need yeah because they need to
collect sales tax on you so you do need
it even though if you're not buying it
wholesale you just need the permit to
buy wholesale items so yeah so basically
what I'm saying is like he's buying
let's say toys and things that are like
like just consumer products but then how
is he justifying reselling it like don't
you like so if you're selling it online
and you're not selling to residents of
your state you don't have to collect the
taxes so I don't even think you need a
resellers permit then I mean ethically
it's like you [ __ ] bastard yeah I
guess there's not you're not bringing
any rules thank you you've convinced
people to buy stuff from you you
basically did the the shopping for them
like you got all the deals and then
you're just kind of the middleman taking
your middleman kudos to you yeah cuz now
four years live job he has a team of
eleven and they make a [ __ ] over 200,000
in sales per month what yeah and so now
he's that's amazing he's selling does he
have a doozy of a page on Amazon yeah
what's his page I probably bought from
this fool me too so
everyday just visits different Walmart's
and targets and buys all their employees
and so what he does now is that he uses
Amazon's fulfillment program where he
just gives them this stuff and then
Amazon ends up sending it and shipping
it to the customers that buy it because
before then that's how all the inventory
was taking up in his how does she how
does he know what products he's gonna
get it's all based off of the clearance
rack that's why he just sells like
random [ __ ] because then he'll end up
comparing it with the Amazon seller app
to see like how much this product is
going for and then how much of a profit
can I really gain I've done that to
where I try to buy the same item like
once it runs out like I try to go back
to the same seller and buy it and
they're like this items are longer
available so it could be that guy yeah
that's dope oh no all I'm saying is this
sounds like a lot of work it is a lot of
work to me but are you making 200
thousand a month give a [ __ ] I do that's
a lot of money all right my bad like
work work/life balance
you don't I mean so I imagine this guy
I'm not hating on though I think it's
dope but then like he's from Minneapolis
yeah if the amount of work takes up my
whole life just to have money then the
money is useless because I don't get to
live life yeah so it doesn't [ __ ]
matter putting in for the future because
then he said like he was taking a salary
of about 150,000 a year when he was
working full time for that for his own
company but then now that he has a team
and like he does whatever you the work
to other people now he has a way less
salary I think it's 60,000 a year now
and so I mean he's not like just all
about the money
also I'm not saying it's all about the
money I just I just don't like working
is what I'm saying I yeah but I never
went to a store I always went to yard
sales and I accumulated a lot of [ __ ]
and I sold it on eBay and that was
really fun to do yeah until I realize
you can't always guarantee [ __ ] at yard
sales you could go all [ __ ] day and
go yard sale hunting in your life this
is garbage I cannot sell any of this
[ __ ] he was also saying like they've
encountered you know some issues where
they've lost money because let's say
they buy out they get a whole bunch of
inventory this one product and then they
send it to Amazon's fulfillment center
and then it just sits there and I never
get sold to them they have to pay fine
of course for them keeping it there so
yeah I mean they have gamble through ups
and downs thanks a lot of work he uses
this one app called [ __ ] Ghouta five
Scout of five he's using here do things
if I these days
yeah and uses it so then like he's
checking a price and the clearance aisle
oh yeah but the clearance aisle doesn't
have that much stuff yeah how much
inventory is he does he have right take
five items yeah his warehouse like how's
he getting boxes of something he think I
feel like there's a missing part of the
story like how was he getting he is in
the Mafia wholesale stuff now or he
could just go to the front and say hey
I'll take every single one of these yeah
for this price and then they'll be like
okay maybe I don't know I think it's
awesome because I got my start in a very
similar fashion but not at this level I
worked at a Target when I was in high
school I did two I was a car technique I
was accorded to you collected yeah did
you have the machine in the [ __ ]
remote yeah yes can bond over then oh my
god that's crazy
it was the lowest of the totem pole job
yeah it's not even cashier we were the
physical labor yeah we were the feel
like and they would call us in to do did
you have to wrap the [ __ ] gate up
with carts yeah you have to you have to
make it at the end of the agenda today
you have to like make know where you
guys [ __ ] up you guys should have been
a cart technician at Costco they pay you
$13 an hour we got seven an hour you
seven an hour yeah I was in high school
I was 18 well said it was like seven
years ago my friend worked there he was
got he got starting pay $30 and and free
hot dogs yeah that's more Cecil
management in Costco they make like six
figures so well there are Union too I
think
yeah yeah that's crazy no every time I
see you whatever I see like when I go to
Target I see people like take their
carts out and you only have one bag in
them I'm like I'm super jelly dude I'm
like you it's one bag you don't need to
take your car I used to be a car
technician
oh yeah some of the things that you're
just annoyed of because you're like why
do you just [ __ ] leave the car
they're like come on it's like three
steps to the - put it away man and
there's some kids I'll be like one
giving you a job who said that no no
I've heard my friends say that about
like things like like jobs like that
punching me the kid dude yep
have you ever had to deal with people
that left [ __ ] dirty diapers in a
cart oh my god I've never understood
that believe it in the cart wait I think
that's a normal thing like people leave
dirty diapers I see it a lot I see it in
the hood all the time like if you're
parking and then you go oh yeah yeah and
then you'll see it on the floor throw it
away dude what the [ __ ] it only takes
you ten steps to go to the trash can
what what am I think if you have a baby
like have some doggy bags with you to
put the bug in diapers in and then throw
it away when you have to see a trash can
and somebody it's already pretty like
sanitary by the time you wrap it up
anyways yes
I just think here yeah so now Ryan is he
consults and he teaches ecommerce
classes and it also has a vlog he
teaches that he teaches that now I'm
gonna teach you how to be a Chinese
person
yeah my name is Ryan Grant
[Laughter]
[Music]